what is your advice to a young person  who wants to pursue screenwriting I mean  right right right as much as you can  which is really difficult writing is  hard and I would say to the subject of  writing don't judge your drafts right  away don't tell yourself oh it's dumb I  don't like it and throw it away really  get it in in front of people have  readings is a really easy way to just  hear it out loud and kind of get it  outside of your own head and you know  the prospect of making a movie can be  daunting but getting friends together  who are actors or even other just people  that you know and you like to just hear  it out loud is is cheap and it's it's  accessible and it forces you to listen  to your work with with new ears I would  say make your own because I think  screenwriting is so much you know it's  always a blueprint for the movie and I  think directing what you've written is  is a good litmus test to see if it's if  it's working